>> Hello.
This is Lydia Fleischman from
NCBI.
And on behalf of the team, I
wanted to greet everyone here in
the Spheres meeting, and thank
you, Duncan, for having us.
We'll be having a couple of
people from our team speak today
about sequence submissions,
specifically of SARS-CoV-2
sequences, both unassembled and
assembled, as well as a great
annotation tool, VADR, which
Eric Nawrocki will be speaking
about.
And then we also just kind of
wanted to emphasize the dialogue
that we want to keep open with
this community and with the
greater community.
Eric, if you could go to the
next slide.
We wanted to engage with you and
really continue a dialogue on
NCBI submission.
We want your feedback on our
existing processes and data and
tools.
And so, we really welcome this
opportunity to do a refresher of
what we have for SARS-CoV-2
submission to SRA and GenBank,
introduce that helpful tool for
annotation that I mentioned, and
share a little bit about ongoing
opportunities for feedback and
interaction with the NCBI team.
And with that, I will pass it
over to Eric.
>> Okay, thanks, Lydia.
So, my name's Eric Nawrocki.
I work at NCBI.
I'm going to be talking about
VADR, which is the software tool
that I'm the lead developer of
that is used for SARS-CoV-2
analysis.
So, we use it to validate and
annotate incoming sequences.
So, it's a general tool that you
can really use for any type of
viral sequence.
And it does the annotation and
validation based on a reference.
I'm going to go into detail as
to how it works, but at a high
level, it does that by aligning
sequences globally with respect
to the RefSeq.
It can also use a profile model
for SARS-CoV-2.
We just use a single RefSeq, but
it's designed to use profiles
also.
So those are models built from
an alignment of sequences --
representative sequences instead
of a single sequence.
We originally tested it for
dengue virus and norovirus, but
it's been in use for SARS-CoV-2
since March on a kind of manual
base.
It was being used manually
early and then switched to a
more automated pipeline in June.
So, this work was published in
BMC Bioinformatics earlier this
year.
Okay, so, to kind of introduce
the motivation for why we
developed VADR, I'm going to
talk about kind of how sequence
submissions go just very
briefly.
So, at NCBI, at GenBank, we have
indexers.
Linda Yankie is one.
Vince Calhoun is another who
deals with SARS-CoV-2 sequences.
And they take the incoming
sequences and metadata from the
submitter and are in charge of
determining if they should be
accepted into GenBank or if
they should be returned to the
submitter for further validation
or because there's some issue
with them.
And so, we developed VADR as an
annotation tool for viruses,
specifically to help the
indexer.
So we know that there's other
viral annotation software out
there, some excellent software
that we could have used.
So, VIGR is an example, VIPR,
VAPiD.
These are really great tools,
but we decided to develop our
own software because we wanted
very precise control over which
sequences would automatically be
let into GenBank versus -- and
we call those passing sequences
versus sequences that have to be
looked at by a human indexer.
So it's really important that we
don't want to let any sequences
that are bad automatically into
GenBank.
So VADR identifies many
different types of issues with
sequences and kind of unusual
features of sequences, some of
which may be innocuous, and the
sequence is perfectly
biologically valid, but those
situations warrant the sequence
to be looked at by an expert
indexer.
So, that's what VADR does.
It passes some sequences
automatically, and others are
going to fail and be looked at
by the indexer.
And the indexer then looks at
the information returned from
VADR and determines if their
sequences should be accepted
because they look fine or if
they should be returned to the
submitter.
And I'm not showing another
arrow here, but there could be
an arrow here where VADR
determines that some sequences
are kind of so obviously messed
up in some way that they should
automatically be returned to the
submitter without an indexer
having to look at them.
So, some kind of obvious
problems.
So, now I'm going to go into
kind of how VADR works.
And the first step of VADR is to
build a homology model of the
virus you're trying to annotate
and validate for.
So, we do this using RefSeq
currently.
So, this is an example using
dengue, but everything I'm going
to talk about applies also to
SARS-CoV-2.
So, these are all of the
features in the GenBank record
for one of the RefSeqs for
dengue, the type 1.
And I'm showing you a CDS
feature, the gene which is
essentially the same as the CDS
as far as coordinates, the
mat-peptides that the CDS is
broken down into, the mature
peptides, rather.
And there's also secondary
structural elements in the
dengue genome that are features
in the RefSeq, and those are
actually modeled by VADR.
So, when we build a model for
VADR, we build a profile model
called a covariance model that
includes both sequence
information and secondary
structure information.
And so, when it does analysis,
it can take that secondary
structure into account.
These structural elements, stem
loops, come from the Rfam
database, and there are a few on
SARS-CoV-2 as well.
So, VADR -- I'm going to talk
about pretty specifically what
VADR does.
So, I'm going to go through the
four stages of analysis that
VADR does.
On this slide, I'm just going to
list them, and then I'm going to
go into detail for each of them
in the next slides.
So, VADR annotates each sequence
using its best-matching model.
So it's actually set up to use a
library of different RefSeqs and
to select the closest one and
then use that RefSeq to do the
annotation for each incoming
sequence.
For SARS-CoV-2, like I said, we
only have one RefSeq.
So this classification is
essentially to make sure that
the sequence is, in fact,
SARS-CoV-2.
Once it determines the
best-matching model, it then
moves on to a stage we call
coverage determination to find
kind of the local hits against
the model and how they align.
And then there's a global
alignment stage where it
computes a global alignment of
the sequence of the model and
then uses that to map the
features just using the
coordinates of the features from
the RefSeq, just mapping them
based on the alignment.
And then finally, we do a
protein validation stage, where
we translate each CDS and then
compare it to the RefSeq
proteins using BLASTX.
And the reason we have these
four different stages, and I'll
go into this more in the next
slides, but is that each one of
them identifies different types
of issues, or what we call
alerts in the sequence.
And these are going to alert the
indexer as to these unusual
features of the sequence that
they should look at.
So, in the first stage, we have
a library of models,
potentially, where we compare
the sequence against each model
in the library.
In the case of SARS-CoV-2,
again, we only have one, but it
is set up -- The reason I
mention this here is because it
is set up to use potentially
multiple references.
So if we did add new references
based on common mutations in
SARS-CoV-2, you could
potentially differentiate
between those with VADR.
So, we select the best-matching
one, and then that model is used
in all the subsequent steps.
And so, at this stage, I'm now
showing you a table that has a
list of the types of alerts, or
issues, that we could find with
this sequence at this stage.
So, one of them is no
annotations.
So, if it doesn't match any of
the models, that's an issue,
that's a problem.
Could be that it's
reverse-complimented because the
match is on the opposite strand.
And with VADR, you can actually
specify what you think the
sequence is, and if it matches
to a different model -- You can
specify the type of model you
think it is, like dengue, and if
it matches to a norovirus, for
example, that would be a
different type of problem.
So, in the second stage, now
that we have the best-matching
model, we use a BLASTN-like
algorithm to do local-local
alignment between the model and
the sequence.
So, we actually don't use
BLASTN.
We use HMMER3.
But it's the same type of idea.
So, if we have -- I'm going to
go through some example
scenarios.
So, imagine this S1 sequence
here.
Let's say that's a full-length
sequence to the model.
We expect one hit that is
essentially the full length of
the model, and that's expected.
So there's no alerts reported
there.
We could also have a shorter
sequence that's not full-length
with respect to the model, but
the entire sequence is covered
by the match to the model.
So that's just a partial
sequence.
Again, there's no problem there.
But we could have other
situations, like for this S3
example, where the match does
not extend to the full length of
the sequence.
So there's extra sequence on
either "N" that doesn't match
the model because it's not
similar enough.
And so, those are specific types
of alerts that we then report.
And so, in this case, there's
low similarity in the 5-prime
"N," low similarity on the
3-prime "N," and also we'd have
a low coverage alert because not
enough of the sequence matches
the model.
So, in another case, we might
have multiple hits, where
there's a region in the middle
that doesn't match the model.
Again, that's a different type
of alert.
So, at this stage, like I
mentioned, low coverage.
We could still have other
problems that we identify.
We could have the case where two
parts of the sequence match to
the same part of the model.
So that's a duplicate regions
alert.
We could have a case where the
order of the hits with respect
to the model is different than
the order with respect to the
sequence.
So you have kind of the sequence
in the wrong order.
That's a different type of
alert.
We could have hits on both
strands.
I mentioned these low-similarity
issues with the previous
examples.
So, then, on the next stage, we
do another comparison with the
model, and this time we do a
global alignment to the model,
where we just take the sequence,
so, going back to the S1
example, and we align it to the
full model.
And based on that alignment, we
can just map all of these
features and get the "N" points
of all the features very simply.
And again, S1 and S2, we would
have no problems with their
perfectly good sequences that we
don't see anything wrong with.
Now, S3, I showed you on the
previous example, we had extra
sequence that didn't match.
When we do a global alignment,
we're actually forcing it to
align at those N's.
So, I bring this up to point out
that that's why I also do that
other BLASTN/HMMER3 stage
because if we just forced a
global alignment, it would be
more difficult to tell that
there was anything wrong with
these N's.
So, we do both a full alignment
and the coverage determination
step to kind of identify
different types of problems.
Again, with S4, this region
would be aligned.
So, it would be harder to tell
there was something wrong there
without first processing the
alignment.
But we could have other
situations that we do find
problems with now that we're
doing a full alignment.
So, this S5 example, we could
find that when we try to map
this mat-peptide boundary here,
we find that it's a gap in the
alignment.
And so, we basically are saying
we're not sure where that
position should be for the end
of that mat-peptide.
And so, that's a different type
of alert.
We could also have a case where
we have low confidence in those
"N" points, so the co-variance
model's a probabilistic model,
and we're able to compute the
posterior probability that any
nucleotide is aligned to any
position in the model.
And that acts as a confidence
estimate into how well resolved
the alignment is there, kind of
how certain the model is that
the alignment is correct.
And if that probability is low
enough, it's basically telling
us that it's uncertain where
that boundary should go.
So that's a different type of
alert.
We also translate coding regions
at this stage and look for
in-frame early stops.
So there could be an in-frame
early stop.
That's a different type of
problem that we'll detect.
So, at the alignment stage,
there's a lot more alerts we can
detect.
Most of them have to do with
coding potential, so mutation in
the start codon, mutation in the
stop codon, early stops.
We could also have mature
peptides that aren't adjacent to
each other.
And I mentioned these indefinite
annotations.
That's when there's a gap or a
low confidence at the end of a
feature.
So, in the final stage, we do
protein validation.
And like I mentioned before, we
just translate each CDS and then
blast it using BLASTX against
the RefSeq proteins, and then we
expect that BLASTX alignment to
be full-length with respect to
the CDS -- predicted CDS.
And so, in this case, if we had
an early stop or a frame-shift
mutation, we would get a shorter
alignment, and that's a specific
type of alert that we report at
that stage.
I wanted to mention Alejandro
Shaffer is a colleague of mine
that implemented this stage.
So, at this point -- Sorry, in
the protein validation stage, we
identified these early stops.
We also report an error if the
blast alignment doesn't extend
to the end.
And also, we look for very large
insertions or deletions at this
stage, and that's a different
type of alert that's reported.
So, that's how -- Those are the
four stages of VADR, and that's
how VADR works in general.
And those are the alerts that we
develop when we're testing for
norovirus and dengue virus.
When we started to analyze
SARS-CoV-2, we realized that
there were two issues that we
had to address specifically for
SARS-CoV-2.
So, the first one is the
processing time.
So, the co-variants model
alignment, I mentioned that it
incorporates secondary structure
into the alignment.
That comes at a computational
cost that's a more expensive
algorithm than just
sequence-only alignment.
And for SARS-CoV-2, it's so
long, and that algorithm scales
with more than the cube of the
length of the sequence.
So it's especially slow for very
long sequences.
For SARS-CoV-2, it was taking
about five minutes for a
full-length sequence.
So, that was way too slow for
high throughput.
So we implemented a heuristic
based on BLASTN, kind of
first-pass alignment that
reduces that to about two
seconds per typical sequence.
So now it's not blazingly fast
by any means, but it's fast
enough for kind of the
throughput that we're using it
for for GenBank submissions.
So, the second issue is that
SARS-CoV-2 submissions --
SARS-CoV-2 sequences are being
submitted tended to have a lot
of ambiguous ends in them --
stretches of ends in them.
And if you look at this table
down here, it's showing you the
percentage of nucleotides that
are N's in SARS-CoV-2,
norovirus, and dengue virus.
And more importantly, the
percentage of sequences that
have at least one stretch that's
fairly long.
So, in this case, greater than
50 nucleotides.
And you see about a quarter of
the sequences have a stretch of
N's greater than 50 nucleotides.
The reason that's so important
is because VADR and other
annotation tools rely on
sequence similarity.
And so, whenever there's a
stretch of N's, it essentially
can't get purchase on that part
of the alignment.
It has to rely on the bordering
sequences.
And so, it just makes it more
difficult to do the alignment
correctly.
So, what we implemented was a
method to identify those
stretches of N's, identify where
they map to in the RefSeq --
again, based on a first-pass
BLASTN alignment -- and then
replace those N's with the
expected nucleotides just taking
them directly from the RefSeq.
Then we do the full analysis
using those sequences with those
N's replaced.
And that seems to work pretty
well.
So, what I'm showing you now is
the observed counts of the
different types of problems that
VADR is identifying in
SARS-CoV-2 sequences.
So, I just want to make two
points.
I'm not going to go through all
of them.
But the two points I want to
make are there's many different
types of problems.
So, it's finding a lot of
different issues.
And some of them are much more
common than others.
So, that duplicate regions is a
pretty egregious problem, but
it doesn't happen very often.
The more common ones are like
CDS with an early stop codon,
for example, or other problems
with the BLASTX alignment not
extending far enough.
So, now I'm just going to go
through just two examples of
real SARS-CoV-2 sequences and
alerts that VADR reported on
them.
So, this first one was actually
fairly early.
This was, I believe, a sequence
from February.
And this had this error,
duplicate regions, where it
identified that there was one
part of the sequence that
actually maps to the same part
of the model.
Or sorry, two parts of the
sequence that map to the same
part of the model.
And this is the alert.
This is the message that VADR
reports.
It tells you the coordinates of
where those -- So, this is the
region that overlaps.
And it tells you that
information so you can then go
and look at it.
It also identified that at the
beginning, there was a stretch
of 24 nucleotides that didn't
match to the model.
And again, at the end, there was
a stretch that didn't match the
model.
And so, now I'm going to show
you an alignment of those
regions.
>> Eric?
>> Yes?
>> This is Ryan.
Lee Katz in the chat asked a
question that I think you could
clarify quickly, which is just
when you're substituting the
RefSeq sequence for the N's of
the submitted sequence, that's
just for the purpose of the QA
step.
That's not making it into the
GenBank record, assuming it gets
accepted, correct?
>> Correct, yeah.
I should have been more clear
about that.
Yes, so, we replace the N's with
the RefSeq nucleotides, do the
full analysis, and then put them
back, basically, before it goes
into GenBank.
Okay, so --
>> I apologize, Eric.
Can I follow up on that?
>> No, go ahead.
>> This is Lee.
>> That's fine.
>> I just ran VADR for the first
time this morning.
So this is fresh on my mind, and
it's great.
>> Okay.
>> And so, when I ran it, it
produced that table file, which
means I could take my genome
assembly and upload that to
GenBank with those annotations.
Is that possible that those
artificial annotations could
make their way to GenBank just
by what my work flow was?
>> So, you're talking about the
boundaries of the annotation.
So, do you mean, like, if you
had a stretch of N's at the end
of a CDS, that the boundary
would be an "N"?
Is that what you mean?
>> So, like, the boundary of the
gene might be artificially kind
of guessed on that QA/QC step,
but that might also make it into
the table file, which I would
then upload to GenBank.
>> So, there's rules in GenBank
that, for example, CDS cannot
end with an "N."
So, those positions get what we
call trimmed.
So they get modified to the
3 prime most -- like, if it was
at the end of the CDS, the 3
prime most non-N, and then we
add this, like, "greater-than"
sign that indicates that it's
not to the end -- it's partial,
basically.
So I don't know if that answers
your question.
So, VADR should generate the
annotations, like, with that
greater-than sign, instead of
saying that it's a full-length
CDS.
Does that answer your question?
>> Yes.
I think I'm understanding that I
might have some -- It's possible
I have some noise in the table
file locally, but the GenBank
submission process would catch
that.
>> I believe that's right.
so, there's additional steps
that are done to go from the
VADR output to the final files
that go into GenBank.
Linda Yankie can speak better to
it than I can.
So maybe we could bring that up
with her.
And also, you can e-mail us and
give us a specific example, and
we can look at it also.
>> Thanks, I appreciate it.
>> Sure, no problem.
Okay, so, for this first
example, I'm now just showing
you an alignment of what that
looks like in the actual
sequence data.
So, at the 5 prime end, there
was a problem where this
sequence was not similar enough,
and that actually matches to the
end of the RefSeq.
So there was some problem with,
perhaps, the assembly of that
sequence.
And again, at the end -- so,
this is now the 3 prime end --
this region matched best to the
middle of the RefSeq.
And that was actually reported
by VADR, that it identified that
that region was duplicated.
So, that's one example.
In that case, the sequence was
trimmed by Linda, and it then
went in.
So, those N's were trimmed
because they were deemed to be
not accurate.
So, for the second example, this
is a more recent sequence.
And in this case --
>> Eric?
>> Yes?
>> So, going back to the
previous one, the low similarity
-- and this is Pavitra from
University of Washington.
Does it also call an error for
low similarity and if there's a
differing number of A's in that
poly-A at the end?
How sensitive is that?
Because I've seen a lot of ours
get called out for that reason.
>> Right, so, that's something
we've talked about.
So, the end -- Yes, it doesn't
treat that end very differently
than any other region of the
alignment, although it could.
So, if it doesn't match well in
this poly-A track, it could
potentially report an error in
that.
If that's something that's
happening a lot and it's
biologically valid, that's
something we can look at to try
to, like, come up with a way of
dealing with that specialty.
So, if you have a lot of
examples of those that you want
us to look at, we can.
>> I just feel like we shouldn't
penalize just for having, like,
three A's at the end, versus the
exact number as the RefSeq
because I guess, you know, like,
your assembly might just
generate those many, and we try
not to introduce, like,
additional things from the
reference, for obvious reasons.
But that's just what the
assembly came up with.
>> Right, yeah, no.
I think I understand.
It's just, like, because it's
treating that the same as any
other part, it's going to throw
an alert, but like I said, I
agree with you, and it probably
shouldn't.
So, if you have examples of
that and you could help us out
by sending them, we'd be happy
to look at that.
>> Sure.
Will do.
Thanks.
>> Okay, so, for this second
example, it was just an early
in-frame stop.
So, this is in ORF8, I believe,
which commonly has issues like
this, where there was a stop --
342 nucleotides, 5 prime of
where it was expected to be,
based on alignment to the
RefSeq.
So it was an early stop, and
this was detected twice, both in
the alignment stage, and then
again in the protein validation
stage.
But they're both saying the same
thing, although it's two
separate alerts.
And then if we look at the
sequence, this is an alignment
of ORF8.
It's part of the alignment.
It starts at these positions.
This sequence starts in the
second nucleotide of the RefSeq.
So these numbers are off by one.
But it's completely identical,
except for this one mutation
here.
And it's changed the GDA in the
RefSeq to a TGA.
Yeah, so, it's introducing the
stop, and that's what it's
detecting.
In this case, Linda went back to
the submitter, who kind of
verified that it was correct,
and this sequence went in as it
was.
So this is an example of a VADR
problem that turned out to go
into GenBank because it wasn't
actually a problem.
Okay, so, I'm going to wrap up
in the next couple slides.
So, I just wanted to mention
some limitations of VADR.
So, one of them is it works in
nucleotide space.
We did that mainly so it could
do global alignment of the full
genomes.
But as many of you know, if you
work in protein space, you have
more statistical power because
of the larger alphabet.
And we're not working in protein
space, except for the BLASTX
step.
So that's a limitation.
Your RefSeq or your model really
has to be representative of the
sequences you're trying to
annotate.
If you have divergent sequences
that have novel stops, like that
earlier example, they're going
to fail.
So you really want to make sure
you have kind of coverage in
your model of everything you're
expecting to allow as valid.
This is a practical one.
So, I mention the slow run time
of covariance model alignment.
It's also very memory-intensive.
So, that heuristic that we
implemented to get the speed
down to two seconds also reduces
memory usage, but in some cases
-- in rare cases, like 1 in
1,000 sequences empirically,
that doesn't really work, and
so, you have to fall back to the
expensive CM alignment.
So you do need 64 gigabytes of
RAM to run VADR for SARS-CoV-2.
And that's a big limitation.
We realize that.
I wanted to point out some
important features.
So, like I mentioned before,
this pass/fail decision is
really important to us, and the
indexers or users have precise
control over that.
So you can change which of those
alerts are fatal versus
non-fatal, so it caused the
sequence to fail or not, as well
as the thresholds for many of
them.
So, VADR is on GitHub.
There's a standalone version you
can download and use for
submitters and also for other
purposes.
So, if you're just interested in
doing analysis of SARS-CoV-2
without submitting the
sequences, there is a separate,
we think, potential pool of
users that would use it for that
case, and also other viruses.
You can build your own models
and use it for them.
It's a general tool, but again,
you really need the models to
cover all the diversity that
you're expecting.
And the way that the alignment
feature mapping works is really
flexible.
So you can have a feature as
short as a single nucleotide in
potentially multiple segments,
and that's what allows us to
handle things like program frame
shifts, where you have a
duplicated nucleotide in a CDS
very easily.
So, just want to mention there
is documentation on GitHub.
I made a special page just for
SARS-CoV-2 analysis.
It's kind of a tutorial of how
to do this, or how to use VADR
for SARS-CoV-2.
And then in the source code,
there's mark-down files.
So, v-annotate is the script
used to do the annotation.
And it has all the command-line
options and everything
documented.
Okay, and so, I think I'm going
to pause now and see if there's
any other questions, since I
can't look at the chat.
Are there any other questions?
>> Hey, Eric, this is Anita.
Just none other in the chat,
unless anybody else has any that
they'd like to volunteer.
>> Okay, thanks, Anita.
>> Hey, this is Jake Garfin at
the Minnesota Department of
Health.
I was just wondering if the
parameters that are used on NCBI
to pass/fail sequences are
available either on GitHub or
somewhere else.
>> Yeah, so, in that
documentation on this page, I
wish I could click on this link,
but, yeah, I think this second
one, it does show all the
parameters.
And that's a good question
because there is specific
parameters that GenBank uses.
And that is available.
>> That's great.
Thanks.
>> Yep.
>> Hi, this is Danny Soriay.
I missed the part at the
beginning where you probably
talked about what the output
was.
Was it, like, Sequin or ASN
format?
>> I did not talk about that,
actually, so you didn't miss it.
So, the output is a Sequin table
file.
It's not ASN.
>> Oh, so, it's something you
feed into TBL to ASN.
>> Correct.
If you're doing it by yourself,
yes, that's an additional step
that needs to be done.
If you're submitting it through
GenBank, they automatically do
that.
>> Hi, this is Pavitra again,
from University of Washington.
>> Hi.
>> I also missed the first part.
So, apologies if this was
covered.
But for those who are submitting
via the web -- the
websubmit.ncbi -- is it at all
possible to have some sort of
machine-readable output format
for that, rather than having
an html report, so that we can
subset sequences and stuff?
>> Right, so, I mean, we're open
to requests like that.
So, that's something for not
just me to answer, but, yeah.
If you have a request like that,
please send that in, and Linda
can speak to you.
>> Actually, I have a slide
about that later.
That will be in the next
version.
>> Yay!
Thank you.
>> At least an attempt.
We'll see if you like it or not,
and we can go from there.
But our first stab at it should
be in our next release.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Hey, this is Lee Katz.
I wanted to follow up on Danny's
question earlier.
It produces a table file, and
I don't know if this is outside
the scope of this talk, so
please let me know if it's
outside.
Is there any way to get GFF
output for things that use GFF
for pan-genomics, or if I just,
like, wanted to do some kind of
rudimentary allele culling or
something.
Like, it might be easier to use
GFF.
>> Yeah, that doesn't exist now,
but it can, definitely.
So I will work on that so it
outputs GFF.
>> Thanks.
>> Yeah, for now, there's an
output file -- .ftr.
It's, like, feature information.
If you need it earlier than
that, that's probably the
easiest file to parse to get to
GFF.
>> Thanks.
>> Yep.
Okay, if there's no other
questions, I will hand it off to
Linda Yankie, who's going to
speak next.
>> So, just a quick recap of
what VADR, and how we use it for
submissions.
First and foremost is speed.
Every submitter will tell you
that the hardest part of
submitting data to GenBank for
them is adding the annotations.
And by providing this tool that
not only you can check your data
before you submit, but also,
we'll run the tool for you and
add the annotation for you.
It saves you a lot of time, and
it also results in data being
released to the database much
faster.
The quality control aspect --
VADR checks the sequence and
does the coding and non-coding
regions.
And if you've looked at a lot of
DNA analysis, you know sometimes
catching anomalies in non-coding
regions is harder to do.
The consistency -- providing the
standard nomenclature for both
the genes and the products.
That's actually an extremely
important aspect for data
retrieval and doing comparison
studies.
And also, there's value added.
Most submissions that come to
us, even if viruses don't
contain all of the mature
peptides for the RNA structural
components, but VADR actually
will add for it.
And note that it does do the
mature peptides on both of the
polyproteins in SARS, which can
be a little tricky, since
they're duplicated.
Next slide, please, Eric.
Eric?
>> Sorry about that.
>> Thank you.
No problem.
So, we do have two mechanisms to
submit.
And we've been talking a lot,
and I'm going to change this up
a little bit because of the
questions that were asked
previously.
And both of the submission
protocols that we have right
now, the common requirement of
FASTA, the source metadata in a
table format, and submitter
information.
you do not need to run table to
ASN yourself.
You do not need to supply that
feature table that's output for
VADR.
Again, VADR's great if you want
to check before you send to us,
but you do not need to supply
that to us.
We will run table to ASN and run
VADR for you.
We have both a web-based
interface and a programmatic
interface.
I believe the last time we
spoke, we talked about the
web-based because programmatic
wasn't available yet.
They're both up and running, and
in both cases, you can supply
the BioProject, the BioSample,
and the SRA run accession, or
the SRR, so to speak, in the
source table, and it will be
picked up and added to your
records.
Provide that link between all of
your data.
While the way that you submit
the data is different, the
reporting system is the same.
So, for both of them, we gather
the files that are supplied, run
VADR to get the feature table,
run table to ASN, and then
output either the error report
or any kind of accession
reports, all of that to the web
for you.
Next slide, please.
So, I'm going to talk a little
bit about the web-based
submission first because that's
what we seem to be getting the
most of right now.
Basically, it's forms online
that prompt you for the required
information.
The source information that you
supply can be a table that you
already have and you import, or
actually, within the program,
there is an editable table so
that you can copy, paste, move
things around, and so forth as
you go.
A big advantage, in my opinion,
of using the web-based form is,
particularly for smaller groups
of submissions, is that there's
real-time validation of certain
things like the country, date,
isolate format or sequence
length and vector screening.
You can see this is actually a
snippet of one from influenza.
That's why the error is about
ceratose.
But the general idea is you'll
get a warning or an error if
something is wrong right away,
while you're actually in the
program, so that you can make
any changes you need to make at
the time.
Errors need to be fixed before
you can move on.
Warnings are for things like,
"Hey, you only put the
collection date year, and it
would be really nice to have
more than that."
So that way we can try and get
as much information as we can.
Next slide, please, Eric.
So, the programmatic submissions
are if any of you -- and I know
there are people on this call
who have used the same system to
submit influenza sequences in
the past.
Essentially, you upload a .zip
archive and a submission.xml
file via FTP.
The archive contains that .fsa,
the source.
.sbt is the submitter
information.
And you can also supply an
optional comment field, a file
that will show up in the comment
field in the final flat file in
the programmatic submissions.
You do need to include that
submission.xml file.
It's basically the directions
that tell us where this data is
supposed to go and what pipeline
to use.
Again, there's some basic
sequence checks that are done as
soon as we receive the files --
the low-quality vector sequence
links, the format.
If all of that and all the files
are there, essentially, you get
a temporary SUB number the same
way you do if you use the
web-based form.
And that will be assigned and
available in the report.xml.
Then we'll go through again, run
VADR, run table to ASN, and any
accessions or files will be
posted on Submission Portal for
these submissions, as well.
Next slide, please, Eric.
So, what I have here is what is
two successful submissions.
This was in our test system, so
all of these are made up.
The first one is using the
web-based pathway, and the
second one is using the
programmatic interface.
You'll notice that the output is
basically the same.
You get the accession numbers.
You get a tabulated file that
you can download that has the
relationship between the session
number and the Seq ID, or
sequence identifier used in your
original submissions.
You can also copy the flat file
and the e-mail that we send to
you when it is released.
If you did not put a hold date
on your sequences, which I hope
most of you are not, this will
be a live link that will take
you to the records in the
database as soon as they appear.
Next slide.
If there is a VADR alert, you'll
get an error report.
Again, the top one is a
web-based form, and the lower
one is a programmatic.
And you can see that there's a
link to an error report.
Again, it says "error," not
"alert."
An error for us just means that
someone needs to look at it.
So, if you were to download that
report and open it, you'll see
this, which is a list of the
errors as they appear and the
sequence identifiers for each
error.
If you click on that link, it's
basically just an explanation of
the error.
In some cases, we can give you
hints as to how to correct it,
not necessarily put a stop code
on, but for other errors, we
can.
If you'll notice the submissions
that came in with the web-based
tool have a "fix" button.
If you click on that button, it
will open up your previous
submissions at the point where
the error was detected.
So, for example, if there's a
problem with a stop code on,
it's going to take you back to
the page where you uploaded
sequences and give you a chance
to upload an amended file of
sequences that corrects that
error.
Because the programmatic
interface doesn't have a web
submission, we can't offer that.
In order to fix those
submissions, you will have to
re-upload the archive and the
submission of that xml file.
Next slide, Eric.
So, future improvements.
What we were discussing.
Just as Eric made changes in
VADR to handle the N's, we've
been making changes in the
validator, as well, and this
will result in less sequences
being flagged for manual review,
and more will immediately flow
through to be released to the
database.
We also want to include another
error report.
So we'll still have that basic,
simple one, but we'll have the
more detailed alt file that is
produced by VADR.
And little snippets of the one
that is generated for the
example -- this is the same
sequence that I showed the
current error report for.
But you can see it says, "CDS
has stop code," just like
before, but now you at least
find out which protein has the
stop code on.
And it has a lot more details in
cases where there's a difference
in the alignment.
The actual nucleotide positions
are shown.
And this will be something that
you can download and parse out
and use to QC the files
yourself.
Okay, next slide, please.
So, this is, as we were saying
earlier, VADR is going to alert
on detected frame shifts or stop
codons.
We know viruses mutate.
We know that a lot of these are
actually correct.
We've had a number of confirmed
mutations so far in the genes
that are listed at the bottom of
the slide there.
As Eric kept saying, we can add
VADR reference sequences.
So, if you know of sequences
that have a mutation out of
place that is consistent -- So,
let's say ORF7a is always
truncated at amino acid 50.
Please let us know, and we can
find the sequence to add to the
reference set.
So, what this will mean that in
the future, if you submit
another sequence that has that
mutation, it will not throw up a
VADR alert, and it will go right
through the process without
anybody having to review it.
So, we'd really like this
community's help in analyzing
these, if at all possible.
If you do have one of these
sequences where you have
confirmed that what is flagged
as an alert is correct, please
let us know.
You can write to GB-Admin, and
you can just let us know the
read coverage over the area of
the mutation.
And if you've not already
provided the SRR number, it
would be great to have that
because one of the themes that
we've had in several of these
talks is trying to link the
assembled data back to the read
data and assess whether there's
any anomalies.
So we really are trying to
promote getting that SRR
information.
And that will actually lead into
Yuriy talking.
>> Okay, great.
So, as I was saying, what we
want to do is create connections
between GenBank and SRA to make
it a lot easier for users to
either get the GenBank data sets
or get the SRA data sets.
It's very common for me to hear
a request from users to go back
and forth, either to get the raw
data, so that they can confirm
findings that they saw in the
GenBank record, or be able to
first look at the GenBank record
before having to download a
large SRA data set and have to
spend lots of time assembling it
and doing other things and that
would instead prefer to look at
GenBank submissions.
So, if you are submitting to
NCBI and you are submitting
COVID data sets, we did create
specifically an umbrella
BioProject for all SPHERES
submissions, which you can see
on the slide.
And if you are starting out a
new project yourself, you can
enter this umbrella BioProject
as part of your initial
submission to register your own
BioProject.
This way, all of the BioProjects
submitted under SPHERES would be
grouped together, making it that
much more easier to retrieve the
entire data set, if somebody
wanted to process things in
bulk.
So, you know, you can make sure
to use the same BioProjects and
BioSamples in both your SRA and
GenBank submissions to make it
easier for us to interconnect
the data sets on our back ends.
Next slide, please.
So, if you're getting started
with SRA submissions and you've
never submitted to us before, we
are the raw data repository, and
as you're submitting to SRA, if
you've never submitted a data
project, you can submit your
BioProject and BioSample, which
is basically your study and
sample registration as part of
the SRA submission.
So you don't need to do this
piecemeal if you have all of
your data together at the start
of the submission.
We do have very flexible upload
options.
We have web uploads through
basic drag-and-drop.
We have an FTP upload method.
And we can get data from AWS
buckets directly.
We are working on getting data
from GCP buckets, but that's
going to come probably next
month, as we still have some
development work to finish up
for that.
But there are multiple ways to
upload to us.
And of course, we have the same
programmatic submission pathway
as GenBank.
So we use the same back-end
system to do all of the
submissions programmatically.
So, should you want to submit
10,000 or more samples at the
same time or over the next year
or two, that is definitely a
great way to go about it so you
can drive your submissions off
of your own limbs or database
that you use for storing and
organizing your own internal
data sets.
Next slide, please.
As you create SRA submissions,
once it's submitted and SRA has
had a chance to process it, we
do provide a way to modify the
contents of the submission
through a web interface.
If you go to our submission
system, it's called Manage Data,
and you have several things you
can do.
You can create reviewer links if
you're doing submissions that
are part of a publication.
So you can send a link to a
reviewer so they can take a look
at the samples and the
descriptions of the data sets
you've submitted to us and how
it applies to your publication.
And you can edit your title,
descriptions of your
BioProjects.
You can add grants and
publication links after the fact
of submitting the publication.
And of course, you can modify
SRA data, as well.
We don't allow modification of
the actual files you submitted
that requires a new submission.
But any type of metadata that's
text-based, you can modify it
through the web portal, and it
usually gets processed and
incorporated very quickly,
usually within minutes.
It might take a little bit
longer for it to appear on our
web pages, but that just is a
matter of getting indexed.
And I guess I wanted to throw up
some statistics.
So, we've had roughly 11,000
runs from USA.
Overall, we have around 100,000
runs from around the world.
And the 100,000 does include
USA.
So, we do have a large amount of
COVID data that's available for
you.
And the best part about it is
all of this data is part of the
AWS open data program.
So it's available to download
for free.
You don't have to be in the
Cloud to use it.
You can download it to your
local compute form and process
the data there.
And we do provide multiple
different formats there.
So feel free to check it out and
let us know when you need
feedback.
Next slide, please.
So, the last slide is We're Here
For You.
We've done lots of things with
your input that have made very
good improvements to our system,
such as the programmatic
submission options, the file
upload drag-and-drop for the
system.
We've had multiple documentation
edits thanks to the feedback
we've received from the SPHERES
group.
But we do still need feedback
from you guys to continue
improving our services.
We certainly have some BioSample
linkages and data flow
discussions for GenBank
submissions.
We've briefly talked about how
to do programmatic submissions
for SRA and GenBank at the same
time.
And for SRA, we do have what,
for now, we're dubbing the
"human scrubber" tool for being
able to identify human reads in
raw data files and being able to
remove them so that if you're
submitting data to SRA and
you're worried about human data
being present there, this tool
could help you remove those
reads.
But we definitely need feedback
on that tool.
So if you're interested for any
of these things, please just
contact us and tell us you want
to be a tester or provide
feedback, and we'll definitely
schedule an interview with you
so that we can hear all of your
feedback.
So, thank you.
>> I don't know if we'll have
time for a Q&A.
I realize we're at time exactly
now.
But the good news is I think we
will continue to have NCBI
updates and discussions.
For one thing, I think we can
continue some of the Q&A online.
But I think NCBI's committed to
doing a series of updates over
the next couple months on
different topics.
So I think it'll be a great
opportunity to pull back the
curtain on some of these and
really provide some user
feedback, which I think is
absolutely critical on the NCBI
side.
I'd really like to thank Lydia,
Eric, Linda, Yuriy, Anita,
Eileen.
Am I missing anybody?
Great work from the NCBI team.
I think this has been very
insightful for me.
I think just given the quality
and number of questions, I think
there's a lot of interest in how
to work better with the NCBI
resources and to ensure that our
sequences are submitted and
annotated properly.
So we're excited by that.
Thank you all, and we will talk
soon.
Lydia or others, do you have any
sign-offs or anything you need
to add?
>> Thank you from NCBI.
>> Alright, thank you all, and
we'll see you all next week.